Hey,
what's going on is bill barn is time for
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 30th, 2016. How are
you? How's it going?
Oh Wow.
Oh look at show. What do you
do it for Memorial Day? Yeah.
Yeah. It's, you fill up the above
ground pool. All God bless Ya.
God bless Shelby over with the cup.
You know what I pinch me can
late Stacey. Stacey, Stacey,
Stacy. Yeah. Over here. You
know what I paid tracon lately.
I don't know why I started drinking
the course light again. Remember them?
Silver Bullets fucking prom night.
Um,
how many did you get in you clamp?
Oh, Jesus Christ. I'm Happier
Memorial Day. Everybody.
Thank you to everybody in the military
for doing what it is that you're dope.
Um,
so that morons like me can run their
fucking yaps and not a have a black van
pull up and take me away
to get reeducated. Um,
that's it. Happy, happy,
happy day off on a Monday.
They should have one of these
a fucking month. You know,
they should have won three
day weekend a month. If, if,
if Donald Trump or Bernie Sanders
would get on board with that,
the two candidates that the people,
people want to go, either one of
them too and they're gonna ramble.
Hillary right down.
You Fuck El Cuckoo clock face
herself right down you fucking
throat. That's what they're
gonna do. I watched this clip
on Facebook, so you know,
it had to be true where Chris Matthews,
right was basically just mind fucking
everybody's saying that Hillary was gonna
win it and blah blah blah, blah, blah.
Just say when she wins it and all that
type of shit and she wasn't doing like,
he wasn't doing like a dude I called
the type of thing. He's just doing that.
Like the, the, the
rich, the rich liberals,
you know those ones, you know the ones
who act like they care about anybody else,
they actually,
they're worse than rich
Republicans because Republicans
don't act like they give
a fuck about other people.
But rich liberals, AH,
they're the fucking worst bleeding heart,
you know,
caring about everybody and
their fucking gated communities.
Oh Jesus, pill the fuck did you have for
breakfast? What did I have breakfast.
I had two eggs over age,
two eggs over easy.
And I always buy these eggs from this
fucking Lily's farm because it sounds like
it's some chick down the street who just
has a hen house and she's making them
from my neighborhood.
But God knows, you know,
it's some giant corporation and I dunno
what the fuck they're doing with these
eggs. They have the thinnest
slash hardest eggshells ever.
So if you tap real lightly poop poop,
poop in the bottom of the fucking pants,
they will not break. And if
he get, then there's this,
this one fucking sweet
spot that you hit the,
you hit the fucking eggshell that will
actually crack and it won't break yolk.
All right? I don't know if you guys
know about this, know this about me,
but I do not break egg yolks.
Okay.
And I'm also superstitious when
it comes to break an egg yolks.
I feel like if you break the fucking yoke,
that means your day is going
to be a shit show, right?
It's a metaphor. You had a plan
and the whole thing went to shit.
And then you got a scramble it up.
Right. That's how I look at it.
So not only did I broke,
I broke one,
the other one was okay,
but then I was just so fucking frustrated.
Cause you want them runny cause then
you still have the nutrition in there.
Right. All these people to
have an overhardt. Yeah.
Over hard like you fucking
arteries. Right. So, uh,
I go to flip the thing and I'm so fucking
frustrated that it's going to turn
into basically a fried egg sandwich.
I got mad and I go to flip the other one.
I broke that one too. And I just was
in my kitchen by myself going, yeah,
there you go. Fuck the whole thing.
Right? Yeah. Fuck the whole thing.
The Nini downstairs are right.
Yeah. By what are you doing?
Ah, just making some eggs,
honey. Does it sound like it?
Okay. Go see interrogation. Right.
It comes to fucking interrogation.
Like Norbert Leo Butz,
his wife on bloodline.
Oh my God. That character is
driving me up the fucking wall.
Not saying the actress, she's phenomenal.
But that whole dynamic, it's like,
can you get just shut up?
Can you leave the man alone?
Is anybody watching bloodline? I'm not
going to ruin any of this shit, but a,
you got to fucking watch it. You
got to watch it. I'm like, uh,
I'm already five episodes into season
two. What just came out? Um, you know,
I had a nice three day weekend, so
Billy fucking red cakes here. I, um,
I've been fucking Netflix the whole
weekend. Started off the weekend.
I watched the do over Adam Sandler's
new movie with David Spade.
It was fucking great. I always loved
San Louis fucking movies and, uh,
I love spades character.
I,
it's hard to talk about a movie
without saying what the fuck happens?
Just watch it. And also just being a fan
of people out here in Hollywood that,
that do their own goddamn thing.
Um,
I guess Sandler's movies crush it
on Netflix. So he's like, well,
why fucking take it to the movie theater?
I'll just take it right to you.
So we cut a deal with them for like, is
next, I don't know, four to six movies.
And they went right right to that. So I
believe this is the first one. And um,
I fucking loved it, man. I loved it.
I got a, I can't say what happens,
but there was just one thing
that Sandler did and I was like,
that's probably going to be the most
disgusting thing I'm going to see for the
first half of the year.
And then something else happens that
involves a fucking old lady. Um,
so there you go. I just prime the
pump, check it out if you get a chance.
And I've been watching
bloodline and then, uh,
somebody else recommended I am road comic
and it was about a, just these comics,
Wayne Fetterman and these guys doing this
road gig and uh, enjoyed all of that,
joy, it, all of that. And uh,
but I mentioned earlier that, uh,
check those out if you can't check
them out at the camp. Anyways,
so I mentioned earlier that I am in a
much more upbeat mood than I have been in
a while. You know, and I know what
you're thinking below. What, what'd you,
what'd you get another bottle of
booze? Now. Not at all. Not at all.
I finally went to a chiropractor.
All right.
I went to a chiropractor, um, and
I never, I never go to the doctor.
All right? Because that's how I was
brought up. Christ, I'm telling you,
you to get down there and,
and you're going to find some
fucking white suit. It's take
a goddamn aspirin. I right?
You hang from a pull up bar,
you'll be fine. All right?
Okay.
I came from a family in a town where
you didn't go to the fucking doctor.
If you went to the fucking,
do you go to the doctor?
You don't take your car to a mechanic
because they're going to fucking find
something. So I finally go
to the chiropractor because
at this point I told you,
I'm literally in the writer's room.
I have cushions from this couch
on the floor and I'm, I'm,
I lay on the floor and uh,
I call it floor pitching.
I just pitched jokes laying on the floor.
And then when it gets to some
critical part, part of the story,
I then stand up to see what's going on.
And then I laid back down and get,
then I just lay in the ground. What if,
uh, what if Frank said, uh, you know,
I'll put you through the fucking
wall. Right. That's what I do.
So I finally couldn't take it anymore
and a buddy of mine who works on the show
said I got a great chiropractor. And I
finally was just like, you know what?
You've got to let that fucking
suburban Boston shit go. Okay.
There's no way. If they always fucked up,
everybody would still be going to them.
So I ended up going down there
and this guy was a fucking wizard.
Unbelievable.
Right?
He literally like put his hand right in
my lower back and was just pushing on my
spine, like on one side of it. And it was
going on. It seems like you have a, a,
an older injury here from a long
time ago. And I was like, yeah,
how the fuck did you know that?
Because now I can tell cause this is bold.
J Like I had a bulging disc and he
goes, hey, I go, yeah, fucking I,
one of my, when I was in
fourth grade, you know,
I was into wrestling and a buddy of mine
knew how to do the figure four leg lock.
And unfortunately the only way to teach
someone how to do it is to put a minute.
And he put me in the fucking thing.
And when I sat up to try to free my leg,
I was the first time I felt uh,
something go out in my back.
And then the next time was
playing football freshman
year of high school pickup
football.
I didn't play organized,
it didn't play organized cause I got a
d in math in fifth grade and that was,
that was,
that was my retirement.
Like when Jordan retired
in 2003 except by never,
I won one championship
and I never returned. Um,
but anyways,
he was able to fix all of that shit.
I immediately felt better the next day
I was sore. And then over the weekend,
like, um, like last night for the
first time in like two months,
I was able to sit down for a significant
period of time and have no pain
whatsoever.
And uh,
I've just been doing all
these stretches and uh,
the biggest one is I've
been doing, uh, that,
you know the up dog yoga stretch for your
a was he a so as muscle in the front,
I just thought it connected you top to
bottom, just where your hips weren't,
it ran perpendicular to your waist.
I didn't realize that it came up and
then Kinda made like an s turn right to
like the middle of your body. He was
explaining it to me. I forget what it is,
but like I've been stretched in that
thing and do what my Vietnamese gambler
squat and a couple of runner's stretch.
And um,
I think by this time next week I should
be, I should be right as rain. And um,
okay
dude, he fucking crack my back. I
didn't know he was going to do it.
I was laying on my back and he goes,
all right, bring your knees up,
bring him over to the side.
Just let it relax, relax.
Let me have all the weight
and fucking right there, Fred.
And I just started fucking laugh.
I'm like, dude, what the fuck?
Cause I always thought it was like
they were cracking your bones.
I guess there's gas that they're releasing
in there. I have no fucking idea.
But anyways,
yeah.
MMM.
I Dunno. I, I,
that's something I always have to
remember that just because something's a
racket, does it mean that there's not
somebody that's really good at it?
You know what I mean? Like think of
the reputation that comedians have.
We don't have a good reputation.
We're on offstage or attention whores.
We got the fucking lampshades on our head
and we tell fucking awful jokes. Yet,
despite that, there's still,
you're fucking, you know,
David Tells Chappelle's Louis C K
is and all of those fucking guys.
Um,
so that's what I guess what you gotta do.
You gotta find the Louis Ck of
chiropractice before you fucking go in?
And I think I did.
So,
mmm.
I Dunno,
this is a show.
I don't even know how to get out of this
if it's just something good happened to
me and I told you the story and nothing
bad happened so I don't have any jokes
about it other than I couldn't
find the fucking place. You know,
I was driving over with my phone.
Right. It's directed me over there.
And then in the last second,
um, right when I needed it,
where the building was, I hit like a
whatever, a dead zone and I had nothing.
MMM.
And I walked up to the building
was one of those partially
like rented buildings.
So it looked like it was abandoned from
where I was and I'm looking in and by
now I'm already losing my
shit and I'm like this,
nobody even in this fucking
bill fucking build a faded.
Then I just see this nurse work by
looking at me with their scrubs on like,
what the fuck is your problem? I was
just an, I had to kind of be like,
play it off and then kind of follow her
around the part of the building that was
a actually being used.
I swear to God, man,
I need to learn how to
have patience. I just, uh,
I have zero fucking patients.
I have zero fucking tolerance,
all of that shit.
And um,
yeah,
I dunno.
It's really gonna be the death of me.
I really get to learn of just fucking
relax. It's weird little shit,
Little Shit fucking drives me up the wall,
major shit, a major pains in the ass.
I just laugh and I don't. Yesterday I
was driving my lovely wife back from,
went over to the mall.
She picked up a few things.
We got all the way home by back,
was starting to kill me and she realized
she left one of her shopping bags in,
I'm in a store and she flipped the fuck
out and I just, and I was like, oh no,
it's fine. It's fine. Okay. I don't give
a shit. Right. I drive all the way back.
My back's killing me. I didn't give a
fuck. Totally relaxed. That was fine.
Right?
But then like an old lady walks in a
crosswalk and I have to wait an extra six
seconds to make a left. And I literally
have a meltdown for the life of me.
I can't figure out why that
is. Um, but anyways, um,
speaking of great standup Comedians,
um,
Doug Stan hope
puts something up.
He wrote something,
he's friends with Johnny Depp and he's
going through this brutal fucking divorce
and uh,
I just want to give him props for sticking
up for his friend and everything and
saying something. Cause you know,
you know what's really so fucked up.
All right.
It's for all the shit that happens to
women that guys do to women is fucked up.
But there has been a slight
overcorrection now where if somebody's,
a woman just says you do something
before you're ever tried or convicted,
it just gets put in the paper.
It gets put all over the Internet
and then all you fucking moron.
So 90% of you on the fucking Internet,
just take it as truth.
Take it is fun.
Why do you take it as truth?
Because you want it to be true because
he's doing better than you in life.
I mean, it's fucking unbelievable.
I really believe this. Okay.
If somebody gets accused, okay. Of,
of,
of rape or domestic violence,
they should not publicize the person's
name until they're convicted of it.
I think that's more than fair considering
all the fucking dopes out there that
the second day read something,
go to the Trump,
you know,
let it fucking see what happens first.
See what the fuck happens for us.
All that, that, that whole thing.
Now that all you gotta do is just say it.
The amount of fucking guys who
have falsely accused of that shit,
it's like you literally fucking
with their ability to get a job,
you fucking with your reputation
and you know the deal dude,
like domestic violence and anything
involving sex, that shit never goes,
that never goes away.
MMM.
So,
I dunno,
I just want to give Stan hope fucking
props were actually sticking up for the
guy because there's a lot of people, you
know, because of the stigma around that.
Even if they know it isn't true,
they were afraid to throw their
hat in the fucking ring right now.
I don't know what the fuck
happened to whatever. Okay.
I'm just saying the fact that
somebody finally just said, hey,
this guy hasn't been tried for
anything yet. He's a friend of mine.
I know we would never do this.
It was,
it was refreshing to finally read
that and for somebody to finally say,
you know what I believe is you shouldn't
put somebody's name out there until,
you know, 100% tried and convicted.
They definitely did that shit.
And then if they did tar and feather them,
but to do that to somebody.
MMM.
And also to give that weapon to somebody
that they can just fucking say that in
blackmail you with that and,
and really destroy your reputation.
MMM.
I don't, it's, it's, it's
fucking reprehensible.
So this is another thing that
isn't really funny, you know,
you know, it's like all those
Duke lacrosse players, this shit,
they just fucking faces all
over the fucking, and you know,
to this day, despite the fact
that they were totally vindicated,
despite the fact that there was the 30
for 30 talking about how bad they got
railroaded despite all of that,
you know,
that's still going to affect their lives.
You know,
there's still going to be somebody going
yeah, but you know, something happen.
You know, somebody when they get mad
and they got nothing else to say it,
they're going to call him a
rapist or something like that.
You fucking know that the
gunner. Um, so I dunno,
I don't, it was, it was good to see and
of course it was stand up, stand up,
stand offs. A good fucking
man. Um, um, as is Johnny Depp,
by the way, the few times that
he's a, he's a big standup,
he comes out to shows he's fucking
humble as hell, you know, gentle.
One of the most gentle fucking people
lever, you know what I mean? Look,
listen to me. Listen how to fuck
I talk. You know what I mean?
You don't understand it.
If it came,
you know somebody said that about me that
he fucking snap like posey and fucking
dirty dozen. I don't know.
I barely know the guy.
I've only met him a few
fucking ties but like I don't,
I really tend to believe what the Fuck
Stan hope is sane and I 100% believe that
you should not be putting somebody fucking
name out there just because somebody
said it. You know? Oh it's fucking,
I'm always fucking status brutal.
She's going for fucking spousal support,
you know going for
fucking spouse's support,
which means he's got to pay her for
like the rest of her fucking life.
She married the guy for 15 fucking months
and your kills me about that person.
She's going to fucking go to
the Beyonce concert, right?
All the date is independent and she,
while you watch your throw
a fucking hand up. Wow.
And Shit gets me heated. All
right, here we go. Here we go.
You're already fucking ribbons,
foot from four guys falsely accused of
rape and domestic violence, you know, is,
did they get their month?
You know, we'll, we'll,
we'll the NFL where a color for them.
Of course they want, they don't,
they don't give a fuck. Um, anyways.
All right, here we go.
Let's talk about, um,
let's talk about that game six.
Holy fucking shit. Game six, Okc,
golden state warriors. And when I
say holy fucking Shit, not only do,
I mean it was a great game.
I mean, holy fucking shit.
You guys going up to sit here and listen
to a man who never watches basketball?
Talk about basketball.
Actually,
I watched the most I've watched this year
and I watched the Celtics mainly. Um,
fucking brutal, man. I will,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I always root for the underdog. So I
was going for Okc, right? Eh, you know,
golden state got this last
year. I like, I, you know,
I've been to a home game
of, um, of the thunder.
The fans are fucking unreal,
and I love their stadium.
It's like a college stadium,
you know,
it's not like fucking triple
decker raw, um, luxury boxes,
like down the staple center,
which every time I go in there,
there's a part of me that gets really
sad for the, for like true Laker fans,
true king fans, true clipper fan said
they got banished that fucking high up.
It's fucking ridiculous. They've got a
Goddamn nightclub in there, you know,
where you can hang out afterwards.
It's the stupidest shit ever. Right.
And meanwhile, all the
fucking, the real fance
okay.
That have been hanging out,
you know,
the only real fan and the lower
level of at the Lakers game,
he got to Diane Cannon and Jack Nicholson.
They've been there for fucking ever.
And I think it was Jack
First. Um, but anyways,
uh, and I, I, I've seen,
I saw Kevin Duran play when he was still
same at key arena when he's still with
the sonics. And I was at that
game when a Okc was playing,
um,
the Miami Heat and Chris Bosh gotten in a,
one of the thunders guys' faces. And, uh,
Duran immediately walked over and said
some shit and broke it up and then he
like was really fucking,
you know, look like,
not yelling but just laying
down the law to his teammate.
And afterwards they asked
him what he said. He said,
I just told them there's a lot of phony
tough guys in the league in that guys,
one of them. And right there,
I mean, he was like 22, 23
when he did it, I was like,
yeah, you got it. You can't
not love that guy. Right.
So I'm rooting for these guys and um,
okay.
It's the classic fucking thing about a
team that knows how to win another one
that didn't, they had those
fights. They actually,
they actually won the fucking game. They
had the fuck. I can't say they weren't,
they had at one,
they were up by seven with four and a
half minutes left and they were playing
like they were down by 15
and fucking the warriors,
they were like, they were
like this patient. Like,
you know when you see like I want to
python grab something and it wraps itself
around you and it just chill it and every
time you exhale it just fucking goes a
little tighter and a little tighter,
you know, and then you're like,
you came fucking bring your pass out
and it's over. That's all they did.
If you rewatch that game, they never
increased the tempo of the game.
They just fucking,
they were like Jason and Friday the 13th
you know when someone's running away,
oh Casey was a victim running away,
looking over their shoulders.
So they're tripping over logs and shit
and they just fucking walked up on him
and that was it.
Fucking machete to the back of the neck.
They were playing like they went down by
15 when they were up by seven and then
they just started coming down the court.
They stopped passing the fucking ball.
And Josh,
that was,
that was one of the most
devastating losses I've seen of,
of a home team in a long fucking time.
They just ripped their hearts out,
fucking held it up to their faces
and then throw it into the crowd.
There was dead fucking
silence except for those 20,
unbelievable stereotypical jerk off
California sports fans that hung around.
They are the fucking worst. Not
all of them, but 80% of them.
They're the fucking way.
Maybe there was a touch of the Yolo
Douche that was fucking going on, right.
You know, the white guys with the hat to
the side and you know, two of them, DJ,
right? Um, they were
standing behind our, uh,
all of the,
uh,
all of the fucking announces they're
near killed me when we were watching it.
She was fucking make it
fun. A shack. He said he,
she said he's one of his big blue suit.
There's big round head.
She said he looked like one
of those talk in m and. M's.
Um, anyways, but Jesus Christ,
Klay Thompson, Mike God,
at what point are you
going to cover the guy?
This is what's so fucked up about
the NBA. You know, when, uh,
when,
what it was fucking name with Steph curry
goes down the lane for like the 50th
fucking time look crossover Hailu Dan,
we'll pop do,
and he's in the air back in
the day that you would've got,
you would've got fucking brought down
to earth on the back of your head.
That would have been it.
And everyone would have stood up and
pushed and shoved and nobody would've got
ejected. He's fucking
like, that's something,
because I watched very little basketball
for a long time during my standup
career and I just cannot believe the
way you can just coast down the fucking
lane. You know what I mean? Back in the
day, if you tried to go down the lane,
you had to be a fucking man. You know,
you knew you were going to add some,
you know, you could get away with it
once, maybe twice. And then that was it.
It was like when Michael Vick was running
around as a quarterback, you know,
eventually one of those linebackers was
going to have an opportunity. And um,
okay.
Yeah, it was gonna you know, this, you
know, if you're a running quarterback,
you know,
eventually,
okay.
You know,
it's almost like considered like a,
I feel it's considered like
a cheap fucking play. Like
we got you guys covered,
you know what I mean? And then you
just going to fucking, you know,
run and then fucking slide on your ass
for a first down that makes people mad on
the defense and eventually you're not
going to have time to go down or they
don't give a fuck that you're going down
and they're going to take the fucking
the fine.
And I'm,
I'm amazed how that has been
taken out of the fucking game.
These guys just glide watch.
'Em
Yeah.
I, I want to say when Mikael hit Rambus,
I don't even know if there was a foul,
there must've been a file, but nobody was
ejected. That would have been like, what?
I don't know.
Whatever the suspensions are nowadays,
three to five games suspensions. But
anyways, um, Clay Thompson, Jesus Christ,
the fucking guy was unconscious and uh,
I got to tell you, man, I just,
okay.
The only reason why I think Okc can win
game seven is nobody thinks they can't.
And that always makes me feel like Vegas
is going to win a ton of fucking money.
I actually have a bed.
I called in the I am Rapaport podcast.
Um,
because Rappaport, anytime anything bad
happens to, to fucking Boston teams,
he's just got a hard on for it.
You know what I mean?
And then he tries to act like he
doesn't give a fuck about baseball.
And then when I bring up how successful
the Yankees are, he flips out.
That's right. That's right. When we
fucking prison rate too, he flips out it,
it literally ages that man,
what has happened over the
last decade and a half,
what we have accomplished
with only four teams,
even a fucking soccer team, if
you want to throw that in, right?
Even they won a championship, it apples.
Absolutely fucking devastates that man,
you know? And all these got
is the two giant Superbowls,
which to be honest with Ya,
you know,
I don't give a fuck if you
told me 15 years ago, Hey,
the patriots are going to go to six
Superbowls and when four of them do you
think I'm going to cry above the
other two? I don't give a fuck
foreign too.
I'll fucking take that.
You know what else would
take the fucking giants?
Okay.
If they could have gone to six and
one four and why wouldn't ya? Ah,
well you know something they
would probably say one and
two against the Patriots
was better. And I would actually believe
that. I would actually believe that.
So whatever. You know what I mean? But
that's the kind of sports fan I am.
I don't have this blind hatred,
you know,
this is the thing of,
this is the thing about me.
As much as I sound like an upper deck,
I'm really not.
Yeah,
I am the way I drink,
I am the way I talk,
the way I curse. I am an upper deck
guy, but I am a logical son of a bitch.
I'm not saying I'm box seats,
I'm on the mezzanine level. Okay.
I'm just that much closer to the fucking,
to the field.
Now Rapaport Rapaport
is upper deck all day,
all fucking day. And if he hears
this, he's going to say he's,
he's actually proud of it.
Rapaport set guy at the top of the
fucking stadium going, is anybody looking?
Is anybody looking at any fucking
takes a piss up in the corner.
You know what I mean?
He actually really is more like
a Philly fan than a New York fan.
He can't help it.
He just can't help it.
Demand demand has in when I hear is hatred
towards Boston sports and when I hear
his excitement every time they
reinstate the Brady suspension,
it just makes me,
it,
I can't even tell you how happy it makes
me that there's a New York sports fan
that is experiencing this level of joy
that something bad is finally happening
to, to uh, a Boston team this
century. It never used to be that way.
You know, you know what New York
sports fans are to Boston fans.
They like your big brother
that used to be able to,
could beat you up until you were about
14 and then you finally kicked his ass,
you know, you know, throw them down
the flight of stairs. You know,
you felt them quit and it's fucking over.
You know,
but it's never over. Cause
you know, at some point,
some point in your thirties something's
going to come back and something's going
to happen at like a family reunion and
they're going to come at you one more
time. Right. You just give him
the old front face luck, right.
And do a back body drop
and then it's fucking over.
When she hid their body hit
that linoleum floor. Right.
The ankle just clips the counter.
They're fucking done.
I love Rappaport, you know. All right.
He's another pasty fucking human being
is out of his fucking mind. Just like me.
All right,
let's read a little bit of advertising.
Literally advertising here for a,
and when I say little, I mean little,
we only got two reads. Everybody. Ah,
when you try to make the reads funny
there it goes to honey right out the
fucking door.
I dollar shave club guys.
Um, I slash we really appreciate you
listening to the show and wanted to do
something to thank you who writes this.
So I slash we contacted my slash
our friends@dollarshaveclub.com
and arrange for
them to give new members a month,
a month of the executive razor for
free just for buying a tube of doctor
cabbies. Easy Shave. I didn't do this.
This is a, this is a bald
face lie. I never did this.
I'm slash we're super excited. They're
doing it for you. Listen, let me,
can I just put it in my own words? Dollar
Shave club's got a great fucking deal.
I'm happy they're doing this for
you because when I was your age,
I had to pay through the nose for fucking
expensive fucking razor blades that
are made out of fucking
plastic and recycled coke
cans and they charge you like
fucking 25 bucks for a pack.
It's complete horse shit.
Somebody saw the opportunity to be like,
Hey,
what if I didn't make a 900000000%
profit and I just made it a fucking 100%
profit? Right? This guy here
at at dollar shave club,
he's like the Robin Hood of the shaving
industry. All right, here's the deal.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
razors right to your fucking door for a
third of the price of what the
greedy razor corporations charge you.
That means when you
join dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic. Get First Class
Shave when you use the executive blade.
That's without even hurting your wallet
and when you use the executive with
their Dr Covey's Dr Carver's shave butter,
the blade just gently glides
for the smoothest shave.
Shave butter isn't your
average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula
with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin feeling
unbelievably soft and smooth.
Now's a great time to
join dollar shave club.
I'm drinking the course late.
Again,
new members who buy a
tube of shave butter.
Get a month of the
executive razor for free.
Take advantage of this
special offer today.
It's available by going to dollar
shave club.com/bird that's dollar shave
club.com/bar dollar shave
club.com/burp all right.
Oh, blue apron. Everybody. Blue
Apron. What's going on? You're dating.
You've got somebody coming over
and you want to cook them a meal,
but you're not confident with your cooking
skills. No worries. Blue aprons here.
All right. Not all ingredients
are created equal, fresh,
high quality ingredients.
Taste better and are better for you,
so it's important to know
where your food comes from.
Blue Apron knows when you cook
with incredible ingredients,
you make incredible meals,
so they set the highest quality standards
for their community of artisanal
suppliers, family run farms,
fisheries and ranchers.
How would you investigate something
like that? This is like some Trump shit.
Where do we have the greatest food ever?
Whether it's Japanese ramen noodles,
wild caught Alaskan salmon
or heirloom tomatoes.
Blue Apron is bringing you the
best for less than $10 per meal.
10 bucks per meal.
Come on.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre portioned ingredients to
make delicious home cooked meals,
um,
new recipes or created each week by
blue apron culinary team and are not
repeated within a year. That's
fucking crazy. Flexible customers,
your recipes each week or
based on your preferences,
choose delivery options if it fits your
needs. There's no weekly commitment. See,
you only get deliveries
when you want them.
Each meal comes with a step by step,
easy to follow recipe card
and pre portioned ingredients
and can be prepared in
40 minutes left.
The only way this could be easier is if
they came over and cooked it for you.
Check out this week's menu.
They should have like somebody from blue
man group come over right with the blue
apron. You know, is there
any blue food, blue potatoes?
I Dunno. Check out this week's
menu and get your two meals free.
Uh,
why didn't they do that on breaking bear?
They should had a guy from blue man group
smoking that blue meth and that right
there is why I didn't write
for the show. All right, free.
All right.
By going to blue apron.com/blog you will
love how it feels and tastes to create
incredible home cooked meals
with blue apron dot. Wait,
that's blue apron.com/per blue apron.com.
A better way to cook a
checkout this weekend's menu
and get to two of your meals
for, for, for free. That's right. With
free shipping. Sorry, I forgot that part.
All right,
let's get back to the podcast here.
MMM.
All right.
So all a oh Billy fucking fat cakes.
I'm in a writer's room and I have my
blew out my fucking sciatic nerve.
Right? I, uh,
so I have not been working out and
I've been trying to eat the best I can,
but I finally bit the bullet and stepped
on the fucking scale the other day and
I was one 83.
So my fighting waits one 72.
I went down to one 63 last year.
I knew I couldn't sustain that.
That was like my emaciated fucking,
you know, underwear model weight.
But I still, you know, there's never been
a redheaded underwear model, a male one,
I don't think, you know,
but there's always a first.
Um, so I really want to be like one
72. So, uh, I just said, you know,
I started yesterday, uh, I got my
birthday coming up on June 10th, and um,
there cannot be an eight anywhere
in my body weight on my birthday,
full life. I've just decided that that's
it. It's not fucking happen. And so, uh,
this morning I was one 81.6,
you know,
I got my gym right outside
my back's feeling good.
I'm actually doing fucking legs and
eggs today, right? Legs and eggs.
The foxy lady. Hey guys, come on
down for legs and eggs. Right.
I'm fucking doing some squats and um,
yeah,
I'll do the gym is the shit,
the fucking speed bag.
The atomic holds the peg board.
MMM.
I just walked right up by one,
a fucking bench.
I don't have to worry about anything.
You know,
I got a wireless fucking
right. I actually don't,
I have this, um, I've got this other
thing, looks like a Marshall amp,
looks like the head of a Marshall amp
and you just plug your phone in there and
uh,
and I just crank like fucking ACDC and
fucking all this shit that I love guns
and roses and all that, like
back in the day. And uh,
my goal is one time in my life did I
ever put up to 25 and for you meat heads
leftover from the fucking eighties to
25 was the shit cause that was two 45
pound plates on both sides.
Right?
And you just brought it down
and right back up again.
And I did that back when I
weighed about a buck 65. So, um,
I am an old man now. So, uh, right
now, you know, I just got the 45,
so on either side, you know, whatever,
I'm working my way back and, uh,
I also know how to build myself up without
hurting myself. I always make sure I,
if I'm going to go 20 pounds up, that I
can do 20 pounds less at least six times.
And then I just go up and see,
you know,
if I can do 20 pounds up like two times,
maybe three.
And I just worked my way up. So, uh,
I literally started out with just
20 fives on either side, you know,
did that 10 times and I threw the
35 10 times and I put the 45 on.
I could only do it like
six fucking times thick.
But now I'm back up to 10
reps on all of those. And uh,
I just moved up to a buck 55, which
I put up like four times. So, uh,
I should have my eighties body back soon.
You know,
we had just totally overdeveloped up
top and then I have my chicken legs.
Now it's not happening this time,
this time I'm actually going to do the
fucking squat, uh, the squats. So, um,
anyways, um, if anybody
else has those atomic holds,
like what are you, cause they
give you those, those little,
those plastic bands that you then put
like the c clamp on and then you can swing
from those things. Like what do
you hook the plastic thing from?
I got him on my chin up bar,
but,
but the shit and the ceiling is like
a fish hook, but it's totally closed.
So I can't put the plastic thing in there.
I guess I could just fucking email the,
uh,
the company and I could figure out how
to do it. Anyways, let's, let's, uh,
literally babbling here.
Oh,
who do you guys like in the Stanley
Cup playoffs in the Stanley Cup final?
Um,
I got to tell you,
after watching the sharks beat my blues,
I have nothing but respect
for those guys now. And um,
I actually really liked that team.
MMM.
But then I got a ton of
friends in Pittsburgh. I Dunno.
I Dunno. I Dunno what to do. Why
is Sydney Crosby so hateable?
Is it the Pouty Lips?
Was it the crying after every fucking
call for so many fucking years.
The guy's unbelievable.
He's unbelievable.
MMM.
I Dunno. I have no idea
who's going to win that one.
But I'm going to watch Barton.
Nick actually invited me over.
I got to get back to them.
Maybe I'll be able to run over there and
watch this and then if I go over there,
I'm not one of those doses that even
if I wanted San Jose to when I would go
over there and I definitely root
for the pence. Uh, you can't,
when you see how happy Joe Barton,
it gives anytime the penguin
score of fucking goal.
There's does no way to
not root for the penguins.
And I'm not even root the penguins.
I'm just rooting
to see Joe Barton a copy.
All right, here we go. Um,
s the questions for the
weak, weak, weak, weak,
weak online dating from a lady.
Hi,
bumbling Billy butterballs. I
liked that one. Fumbling, rumbling,
bumbling, stumbling. Um,
I actually tweeted about you just see
that four year old kid fell into the
gorilla and closure and then they
killed the gorillas. Um, I said, uh,
I tweeted about that.
I was saying how a four
year old does not fall,
accidentally fall into a
gorilla and closure. I wrote,
that was a fun Hashtag. Chris Berman. Uh,
all right.
I am a 26 year old lady and I met this
guy I am really into on an online dating
app. I am not on the APP for hookups
and don't think he is either.
We have met,
we have met up in public places three
times in the past week and I can really
see potential with them.
That's so,
I'm so fucking jealous that you guys
have that app where it's like I'm not on
there just to hook up with people.
Like you literally can turn yourself
into like a Gigolo or a call girl with
regular fucking people. It's
unbelievable. And he said,
we have met up in public places three
times in the past week and I could really
see potential with him. I haven't
been to his actual apartment yet,
but met him once in the parking garage
if his complex and it sounds like a blow
job. Uh, sorry, I shouldn't
have said that. Oh,
he wants to hang out and
watch a movie at his place.
I'm not a prude naive or getting any
weird vibes or red flags from him.
I just don't want to put myself in any
potentially dangerous situations or give
him any false science.
How soon is too soon after meeting someone
online to hang out at their apartment?
Dude, what the fuck? I
don't know. I have no idea.
You don't sound comfortable. So I
wouldn't do it. I wouldn't do it. I would,
uh,
I think if you're going to spend time
alone with him for the first time,
I would do it at your place
and have nine one dialed in
the phone in your hand. I mean,
I don't know if you get in
this kind of a creepy vibe,
are you going to creepy vibe
because, um, you met him online?
Um, I, my advice is a,
I would not go over there anytime soon
until that whole fucking vibe goes away.
Um,
and whether you're approved or not
has nothing to do with anything.
That's just, it has to
do with being smart. Um,
Jesus Christ. Now you got me thinking
there's something wrong with them.
You know what, stay away
from that guy. Um, all right.
Boyfriend doesn't want a dog.
I don't know how to say this.
Hey Billy, is that a French word?
B e with a little hat on the first.
He, now I've got to look it up. Uh, you
know what happens when I do this shit.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, you know what? I actually was looking
up the other day, um, because I'm,
I'm a big fan of the, uh, 83.
Yeah.
Philadelphia 70 sixers.
I was looking up, uh,
okay.
The, uh, Saint Louis spirits,
which was a, um, an ABA team.
Okay.
French to English translation. There
we go. It was, it's an ABA team.
Oh, let me stop it. You fucking asshole.
Um,
okay.
Hey, Billy, stupid. Um, what was I gonna
say? Uh, I actually looked it up, the, uh,
the Saint Louis spirits and,
um,
did some of the cool nicknames. Coolest
Nick's names ever. They had a guy,
bad news, barns, fly Williams,
and then Moses Malone.
Moses didn't even need a fucking
nickname with the, with uh,
with this, that had been his
real name. Moses, Moses Malone,
bad news barns, fly Williams.
And uh, I watched it.
I don't know if there's,
I think there's a 30 for 30 on it.
It seemed like I saw a trailer for it
and Bob Costas supposed to going like,
do you need to know anything about the
Aba? That team was the fucking Aba.
Everything that was great about it.
And I believe Bob Costas
is a Missouri Guy and uh,
so I think that he was doing all those
games. Um, if I ever meet Bob Costas,
that's the Shit I'm going to ask
them about out of fucking everything.
That's what I would want to talk
to him about is about the, uh,
the Aba.
Yeah.
Where he got his start and all that. Just
can't fucking believe that, you know,
he got to see all that stuff.
Um, so anyways, here we
go. Billy Billy. Bet Billy.
Stupid. All right. Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm a longtime lady listener.
I love your standup specials and F
is for family is amazing. Thank you.
A nice work. Thank you. Thanks again.
I'm 29 and I just moved away from Seattle
to San Antonio with my air force pilot
boyfriend hour. Right? A
100 summer is that one go.
If we go into the wild blue yonder,
this is my first time living away from
home and he's gone a lot for work.
I thought it would be a good idea
for us to get a dog to keep me sane.
I love animals and was a part time dog
walker in Seattle. My boyfriend, however,
has never owned a pet in his life and
isn't hot on the idea of having a dog.
He's from Iowa and he believes
livestock should live,
shouldn't live indoors.
Oh Jesus.
I've owned cats and dogs my entire life.
In fact,
I had to leave my 17 year old cat
behind in Seattle and it broke my heart.
Can you offer any persuasive words to
help bring him around or should I just
drop it? Thanks for the laugh
and go fuck yourself. Um,
how do you bring them around?
Well, you could do it. My wife did.
And you foster air, quote a
rescue dog. That's what happens.
You foster a rescue dog,
which means yeah,
just have it for the weekend and as
the bit when in my act I went from,
there's no fucking way I'm keeping this
dog in and a 48 hour period when all the
way to, oh my God, this
thing's going to die some day.
How am I emotionally going to
be able to handle this? Okay.
MMM.
You could do that. Um, I don't listen.
Well this is what I would do either way.
No matter how this works out,
I would get a small dog. Okay. Small dogs.
Small problems. Okay. Small expenses,
small shifts to pick up. Is your
house breaking the fucking thing? Um,
how's training? Whatever the
fuck it is. Not a horse pill.
You don't ride the thing.
Um,
okay.
How would you do this? Well, it
sounds like he doesn't want to do it.
Why would he call it livestock?
Not Livestock. It's a fucking pet.
MMM.
I Dunno. You know what it is. This
is the thing. If you foster a dog,
this is what's going to happen.
So this guy grew up on a farm or he
grew up in Iowa. This is the thing,
when you fucking come home on a farm,
a cow's not flipping out and
excited to see neither is a horse.
They can do little things, but nobody
gets excited like a fucking dog.
You know what I mean?
It's like a Dick Vital Taylor,
right?
John,
you come home,
your dog flips out like you just dunk
the ball on a fast break and the other
team called timeout.
That's the way your dog fucking reacts.
Now I know from experiences when I was
just a boy and I would walk to school and
I used to feed this horse every day on
the way bill, is this a Tom Sawyer movie?
No, it isn't. This was my childhood and I
remember one time it wouldn't come over.
So I walked away and I fuck.
When I look back it was doing that walk
or was nodding its head and flipping out
for whatever fucking reason.
It was like playing hard to get.
So I know that they can, I guess on some
level show a certain level of emotion,
but like, um, I think maybe, um,
yeah,
I dunno what kind of dog, if you get a
little dog that has a nice mushed up face,
you know?
MMM.
Maybe like one of those French bulldogs
something that snores and Farsi you'd
get boyfriend can find it funny. I have
no idea. Uh, maybe a dog like that,
but uh,
I find it hard to fucking believe unless
he grew up on a farm and anybody grew
up on a fucking farm on a certain level.
Like they got this cold blooded
next to them, you know what I mean?
They've just seen too much.
They've seen fucking animals slaughtered,
you know?
Okay.
You know, like when they're a kid like
did dad goes, you want chicken for dinner?
Is that what you want?
She crying. You want chicken for
dinner? All right. He come out here,
you come out of here, right. Come on
out. Which ones is going to be dad?
I don't want chicken anymore. No. You said
you want a chicken up. Pick one APP. Boy,
if you don't fucking, I'm gonna
fucking have you per day interview one.
Then he fucking just grabs it,
puts it on the chopping block,
and then hands that kid the fucking
clever. Go on and do it. I said,
damn right. They live through
that. It like the age of six.
So they don't look at
animals the way we do.
And I gotta be honest with you.
I remember one time I saw this guy shoot
a fucking cow because it was bullying
the other fucking, it was shot a steer
because it was bullying the other steer.
They couldn't figure out why
the, you know, you know, they,
they'd come back the next morning and
like two or three cows look like they
fucking,
somebody tried to do a scrap,
extrapolate some fucking information
from them. Right? Is that the right word?
I don't know. Um, but they
got slapped around, you know,
like they walked into a door and they
couldn't figure out what the fuck,
slapping the shit out of these stair.
And it turned,
they figured out which one it
was. So they were like, all right,
we got to kill this fucking thing,
but here's the deal.
We don't want the thing to be stressed
before it's killed because that'll affect
the taste of the meat.
So what they do is they just sewed it up,
put do booboo, do we do, do they just
sort of pen it in and yeah, you know,
how are you doing? Do we do pick, do. And
then they just fucking take out a gun.
Blam they fucking kill it.
Right. And I was like, oh my God.
So then they,
the guy had like this fucking this
tractor and they tied up the back things,
the back of its legs,
they tied it puts back legs,
and then they just lifted
it up off the ground.
Then they gutted the fucking thing.
All the blood's pouring out
all the fucking end trails.
And I'm just sitting there going, oh
my God, I'm never eaten meat again.
This is fucking horrific.
Right? And then they,
once they fucking chop the head
and the legs off and they get,
they get the for the hide off and
they started chopping it up. Ah,
I went from like,
Oh my God,
I'm never eating meat again to my
mouth watering gone, holy fuck.
Look at all those stakes.
And this guy was cutting them in like
four inch fucking slabs like Fred
Flinstone fucking stakes.
And it's just like, dude,
you could literally eat yourself to death
and not get a third of the way through
that fucking cow cattle or what a
steer or whatever the fuck it is. Um,
so I think the thing about it is, is if
he grew up in Iowa, anywhere near a farm,
that's how they look. And animals,
they look at it like, you know,
this is a food source and don't
get too emotionally attached to it.
Keep it outside.
Do not give it a fucking name.
And when it can't make you any more money,
you give it the old fucking right there,
Fred. So he might be a loss costs,
you know what I mean?
And as bad as that might be for you.
I got to tell you like the fact that he
can wall off those feelings like that is
great if you ever have an intruder
because God help him when that guy,
when the intruder gets
those farm hands around them
fucking throwing bales of Hay since he
was four years at the farm, boy strength,
Jesus Christ, that
fucking, all those fucking,
every offensive lineman for Nebraska
just grew up fucking punching,
steer in the Goddamn head, the
fucking maniacs. So, um, Eh,
the fact that he grew up in Iowa,
it might be a lost cause.
So I would just say try fostering
a dog and try to just get,
get one that is cool and chills.
What if you,
if your boyfriend's active,
maybe you want something that's a
little more athletic but like, you know,
you're going to have a dog
that just wants to chill.
Why you watch the fucking game? I mean,
that's the best. That's why I love my dog.
My dog is fucking shredded. It makes me
want to work out. But then also, you know,
it is down to take a nap and
he fucking time you want,
it's not like those sheep herd and
fucking lunatic dogs that have like add.
And if you don't give it a
project, it starts fucking
eaten the door, you know? Uh,
but anyways, good luck with that
shit. All right. Beyonce is album, uh,
dear Billy def jam.
My girlfriend was listening to the new
Beyonce album for a couple days straight.
I let her listen because, uh,
we usually listen to my music,
which is music she loves.
Anyways, I didn't say it's funny.
I let her listen and you know what?
It's okay. You can listen to that. Um,
I didn't say anything
for the first few days,
but then I just started getting
sick of hearing the same songs.
She understood this and did not take
offense because she's a great girl and I
don't waste my time with shitty
girlfriends who can't communicate through.
I got to admit, right now at this
point, you sound like, you know, a girl.
She's a great girl. As long. She wants
to do everything you wanted to do.
She's a great girl.
I'd say I'm sick of the two days.
I'm sick of your music and she's been
listening to your music for fucking ever.
Uh, maybe I'm reading into
this. Anyways, later that night,
we're at a bar with their friends
or their friend who is really,
who has a really annoying name
that rhymes with small lien.
She brings up the album,
the Beyonce album and how great it is.
And my girl laughs and says, yeah, I
burnt this guy out with it pointing to me.
Her friend saw this as an opening to
regurgitate every stupid soundbite she's
read on a blog.
Apparently I'm not comfortable with women
being in a dominant position or if a
guy did what she did, I
wouldn't care. Uh, yeah,
I know this,
this,
this happened when that Alannis
Morissette album came out and I remember
enjoying some of the music and
some woman in a bar was going like,
do I even know what the song is the
bat like? Like I should like, like a,
like I had some,
a relationship with the Atlantis and
she was yelling at me like I don't
understand it. You know what I mean?
The songs see the fucking, you know,
either like the music or you
don't, I don't give a fuck
what she's singing about.
Right.
MMM.
At the end of the day. Yeah. If you could
fuck me fucking be singing row, row,
row your boat. If it sounds
good, I'm going to listen to it.
Like I'm not necessarily a fan of her
shit but that one that she did with Jack
White,
I liked that song cause cause the song
sounds good and I've heard it like 10
times cause knee has been playing it and
I can not tell you one fucking lyric in
it. I don't know. I don't even know
what it's about. Um, but anyways,
I finally had to interrupt her and
explained that while I think she's,
what she's singing about
is annoying.
You said it annoying is annoying.
My only complaint was that I was tired
of hearing the same song songs for three
days straight.
She wouldn't even listen ignoring me and
the words coming out of my calm mouth
dismissing logic.
I turned to my girlfriend and said,
how can a girl is smart as you have such,
such one dismiss.
Oh,
such a one dimensional friend.
Yup.
She tossed what was
left of her drink on me.
Okay.
Wow.
This chick is way out of line.
It was a beer bottle
that was almost empty.
I barely got any drops on me.
She got mad when I laughed and turned
and stomped off. Did I say too much?
Did I say too little? Listen, I'm not
saying you're not a dick. I think,
uh, I think you said, I think
what you said was perfect.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Like to be honest with you,
at some point your girlfriend should
have stepped in and being lent pen like
guys got, maybe she was guys, guys,
settle down, settle down, settle down. Um,
but whenever an album like
this comes up, I mean, she,
she realizes that that album is just
like a big fucking, isn't that like,
you know,
just like a big fucking, what
do they call it? Trolling,
isn't she just acting like that happened?
I mean,
I don't think she let calluses grow on
her feet and do all that shit that she
said.
She always looks like she just came from
the spa and I don't give a fuck what
that guy did. I don't think
she's interrupting that. Um,
maybe she made the help go
down and go through that,
that biblical Shit that she was talking
about, but uh, but whatever, you know,
they got to have that fucking, you
know, not everything's for you,
but I understand if someone's like
playing an album three days straight,
you'd go fucking nuts. Um, but
I think I,
yeah,
I think you went too far
because you insulted your
girlfriend's girlfriend by in
a roundabout way,
insulting your own girlfriend.
MMM.
You know, but that you have to
understand like women like that,
like in this day and age,
like this is like,
mmm,
this so into that shit that you're not
going to convince them one way or the
other. That's like the type of person
that acts like an asshole and just goes,
you know, guys are intimidated by me and
at no point have they ever examining,
examining like their own behavior.
It's like a, did I tell you what guys,
when I was in Seattle,
when that woman came up and fucking
slammed her hands on the stage,
cause like the stage was up to her chin
and it scared the shit out of me cause I
couldn't see anything
because the lights were on.
I thought someone had jumped on stage.
MMM.
And I felt like that jolt, like right
before you're going to get into a fight.
And I looked down and there
was this woman, you know,
screaming at me or whatever.
And I just said,
first of all,
she was standing there forever and no,
no security did anything. And I joked,
I said to the guys in the
crowd, be like, dude, how,
how many times would we have been choked
out at this point and dragged out of
here and thrown into the throne in, into
fucking traffic. This is one of these, uh,
women privileged moments where you can
just disrupt a fucking show and suits
been standing there yelling at me for
like 30 seconds and nobody moved to do
anything.
MMM.
And then finally I just said, ma'am,
can you, can you please take your seat?
And she goes, Oh, I'll take my seat,
but I don't need your permission is
what she said. And it was just like,
it's like, all right, I get it.
You're a feminist. But like, you know,
you're applying it.
Like in this instance,
I'm not the bad guy. You're,
you're, you're the asshole.
I know you have a vagina.
So that makes you this terminal victim
in your fucking world and that you can
never be in the wrong,
but believer it or not,
at some point you can be
the fucking asshole and
mmm.
What you did was you,
you remain calm.
Yeah.
Which is the way to beat anybody in a
fucking argument is as they get heated,
you just stay calm.
And when she had nothing else,
uh,
she threw your, your drink at you and
then, and then fucking stormed off.
So it was weird you won that
argument, but, uh, your,
your girlfriend and apology because,
uh,
you made shit weird between
her and her girlfriend and
mmm.
Then he kind of insulted
your on girlfriend in a way.
Uh,
having said that, I applaud you for saying
that because that's fucking hilarious.
And I actually wish I could have seen
that because anytime it's those types of
songs come out, there's always said that,
that type of shit of like, uh, you know,
Oh, you're just saying that because this,
you just saying that because that, and
yeah.
You know,
I,
I don't know it because you know what I
don't like about that shit is then you
just, you just have this built in
fucking excuse. So it's like, oh,
so you're never in the wrong, if I
call you out and say, you know, x,
Y, and Z, it's because of my
own issues. It's never you.
MMM.
Jesus Christ.
That takes me back to daisy
Buchanan's in like 1990,
whatever when that Atlanta
more set fucking album came
out. All right, here we go.
Okay.
Bobby boxing or porn.
Jesus Christ is a, uh,
it's fucking wide variety on this one.
A dear bill.
I'm facing a dilemma in my life and I
was hoping to gain an outside opinion.
I'm a 20 year old male and I've
always had aspirations of becoming a
professional boxer.
However, I have a problem.
I fear that I'm addicted to sex.
What?
I already don't believe this. This
is such a fucking left turn. I don't,
I believe this is causing problems
in my relationship with my fiance.
I absolutely,
I'm absolutely in love with this woman.
She goes out of her way to make me
happy, sacrifice. So I got the hiccups.
I wolf down my breakfast before this.
Um,
she goes out of her way to make me happy,
sacrifice so much,
just to be with me and
also pleasures me often.
Rofes what can you just
say? You have a nice,
you have a wonderful sex
life. Pleasures me often. Um,
I got a picture of you with
your head thrown back. Ah,
why would you do that to
me yet? Can't. All right.
The only problem is my
sexual frustration with her.
We have passionate sex many times during
the week, but I still want it even more.
Eventually ending up growing angry and
resentful towards her when she doesn't
want to. Jesus, don't go rub one out,
uh, in later feeling like an asshole.
This brings me to ask myself,
should I just fuck for a living?
My fiance and past partners have always
complimented me on my performance in bed
and my stamina. Jesus Christ. This
guy's going hard on memorial day,
so we have a parade for you going
up to three hours on occasions.
I love the sport of boxing and
have always wore work toward that.
But this problem I have sometimes just
makes me want to drop everything and go
fuck the world anytime.
Any advice,
this is real or fake. This is great. Any
advice you have regarding this problem,
my relationship or career path will
be greatly appreciated. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. Well,
look, if you're boxing, you're
in great shape. You know,
I don't know if you've
got the Porno Dick or not,
but you definitely got
the stamina. Like, dude,
you don't want to go into that world
if you have other fucking options,
you don't want to go into that world.
And um,
okay.
You know that I really,
there's very few like the people who seem
to make them the zillions of dollars,
which is still really hard to do at this
point because porno was become free,
seems to be the women.
MMM.
They seem to be the ones that can become,
be a star just because guys watch
I guess way more of it. Yeah.
MMM.
So I would say, uh, Jesus Christ,
am I going to tell you to go get
your head kicked in or a fucking
go join the dark world of
porn? Um, I would say boxing.
I would say this is what I would do if
I was you. You know, you usually say,
if you looked at you, you know
something with your fucking sex drive,
they always say, you know,
boxes right before a big fight.
They abstain from sex for
10 days. Dude, you know,
you're only problems going to be coming
in. Then your balls are going to be,
feel like they're fucking through
the, the, the, the tarmac would avail.
You call it the squared circle.
Um,
yeah.
I say you keep fucking boxing.
You abstain from sex and uh,
hopefully you're good at,
you're good at boxing.
You know that is not,
that's not a fucking good profession to
just be okay yet because you're going to
be fucking, you know, your
brain's going to be mush.
MMM.
Why don't you just, why don't you try
a, the UFC at least she got a chance.
If you can tap out,
you can just get fucking get.
Okay.
That's it.
You'll get knocked out.
You don't take a bunch of
head shots in the UFC, but I
mean, you can get, you know,
an arm bar.
I'd rather have an arm bar.
They'd be knocked out because you can
tap out before they pop out. You fucked,
dislocate your elbow, you get choked
out, which sounds horrific to me,
but every professional fighter
I've ever seen, it's like, dude,
I'd much rather get choked
out then knocked out.
But you just go to sleep and then
the ref stops. It. If fine. Right.
Um, I've got to tell you, that's one
of the artists questions I've ever had.
MMM.
I Dunno, Dude. But God help you. If
you become successful as a, as a boxer,
you are going to become famous and
God help your relationship then.
MMM.
There's no way to jerk it out of yourself.
Go out and lay on the front lawn,
like one of those sprinklers.
Just fucking,
you know,
shoot all your ges out and then get
on with you fucking day to go do your
roadwork running with your
hoodie and you'd timberlands on.
I don't know what to tell you,
dude. That's, that's way beyond me.
You sound like you need a,
you need a therapist.
MMM.
Jesus Christ.
I want to believe that that one was true.
I don't know about that one. But anyways,
that is the podcast for this week.
Happy Memorial Day.
Everybody enjoy your day
off and I'll check on, um,
on Thursday. Yeah, that's right.
All right. Go Fuck Yourself.